Well,
what about trump?
What's going on there?
Exactly.
You know,
it was interesting listening to trump's
inauguration speech because are detected
elements of national socialist thought
in it,
you know,
and not being dismissive.
I'm seriously not being dismissive,
but when you radically activate on the
side of the left,
you call forth compensatory forces and
they're not in your control.
And like Trump opened his speech.
You just read it.
It sounds like a 1950 socialist,
you know,
he's going to use the power of the state
to bring the industry home to produce a
lot of infrastructure.
It's a state business unity with the
state in charge.
And then at the end of his speech,
which is where he stopped speaking,
at least the international kind of
socialist,
he says,
well,
borders are really important and so is
national identity and you know,
he does embed that within belief in God,
which is probably a good thing,
assuming that he's serious about that.
But you know,
the fact that trump was elected in the
end,
that there was such a fight between him
and the Clintonites and that the Clinton
nights were playing identity politics
instead of speaking for the working
class,
who then trump co-opted,
like he should have.
Um,
there there's a war going on there.
And then what about brexit?
What's going on there?
And what about France with Marine Le
Pen?
And what about Holland with wilderness?
You know,
watch it.
We're in a chaotic time and you know,
I've got letters from people all over
the world who tell me how they can't say
what they think.
It's like,
oh,
well that's not very good and they're
kind of happy with me because maybe they
think that are emboldened them in some
way and so good,
good for that.
Hypothetically.
And most of the people who wrote me the
overwhelming majority were reasonable.
So pretty happy about that too.
But,
and maybe I'm wrong about my damn
diagnosis because like what do I know?
But I do have this proclivity to get to
the bottom of things and what's out the
bottom of this as an ideological war or
philosophical war.
It's even deeper than that.
It might even be deeper than a
philosophical bore,
which is something that's more like a
metaphysical or theological war.
You know?
It depends on how far down you look and
the postmodernist know exactly what
they're doing.
This isn't accidental.
Of course you shut down speakers you
don't agree with because you can't have
a dialogue within then anyways because
human beings can't have dialogue.
There's no such thing as a human
individual.
There's no such thing as truth.
Here's the postmodern world.
It's the hogs nightmare.
It's everyone against everyone else
except it's not individuals.
It's groups and you're stuck in your
damn group and it's the only thing about
you anyways,
that's relevant,
which is why we might base our hiring on
it,
for example,
and you're oppressed and even if you
don't know it just only because you've
internalized it and it's the only thing
that's real about you anyways.
And I can't talk to you because I'm in
my own little silo of privileged belief
and besides we can't use logic because
that doesn't exist and so you're in a
group and I'm in a group and all we can
do is have a war or we can talk,
but we don't get to talk because he
can't talk if you're a postmodernist
because speech is just chatter,
so when it's just chatter that supports
the people in power,
that's how they think and so the whole
world is this little arm war of identity
group against identity group against
identity group,
and you shut down people who don't agree
with you because why should you let them
talk?
It's you don't believe in any of the
reasons why you would let someone talk.
So this isn't accidental.
It's not [inaudible] they're afraid.
Although it's also because of that,
they hijack,
you know,
fear.
They hijack compassion.
They make anyone who who puts forward an
alternative view into a terrorist of
ideas and someone who's heartless at the
core,
which is really incredibly intelligent.
It's such a good strategy.
It's so devious and brilliant and it's
so effective because who wants to,
who the hell wants to be labeled a
bigot?
You probably are a damn big.
It's just like everyone else.
So you know,
and it's easy to make people feel guilty
about that.
Maybe they should.